Speaker 1: All right, so let's take a look
at some of the delusions that were taking
place at CPAC this weekend.
Now, really understand that CPAC, the Conservative
Political Action Conference, put on by the
American Conservative Union, it used to be
mostly like a pretty standard Republican event.
You know, they would say things I disagreed
with about taxes.
I wouldn't agree with them on health care.
I wouldn't agree with them about abortion.
I wouldn't agree about gay marriage or foreign
policy.
But it wasn't always a totally nuts Cunanan
conspiracy type event.
CPAC appears to now have completely surrendered
to the most extreme conspiratorial, unhinged
elements of the party, essentially like the
wackiest of the pro Trump wing of the Republican
Party and hilariously, a seven point plan
to reinstate Donald Trump in days rather than
years.
Yeah, was handed out at CPAC.
This you have to see.
And interestingly, it does include one point
from our story.
A few weeks ago, the idea of Trump becoming
Speaker of the House, Andrew Solander from
Forbes tweeted about this.
CPAC attendees sent me this picture of a card.
They were handed about a seven point plan
to restore Donald Trump in days, not years,
which involves installing Trump as speaker
and ousting Biden and Harris.
So let's look at the plan point one by the
notice that the first point is meaningless.
The first point is reveal Achilles heel.
Pull back the curtain on the horror show that
is today's Democrat Party.
Watch Pelosi melt like the Wicked Witch of
the West, see the Black Caucus and other key
groups flip unexpectedly and watch the tables
turn fraud the second.
That one's meaningless.
OK, the second item just means they want to
win the next election.
It's not really a plan.
It's sort of like what political parties do.
Number two is witness, a trusted conservative,
elected a speaker of the House and finally
reveal suppressed results of existing investigations
into election racketeering.
The second part won't happen because they
just lost.
But the first part is like just win.
Then they want to correct the official record
and reveal that Trump legitimately won the
twenty twenty election.
Their fourth part is that the speaker of the
House will draft articles of impeachment for
Biden Harris that we know that that's what
they want to do.
If they win the house in twenty two, then
they will elect Trump speaker of the House.
Now, remember, we talked about this some weeks
ago.
You actually don't have to be a member of
Congress to be speaker of the House.
Traditionally, that's the case.
That's the way it's been.
But Trump could be made speaker without even
being a member of Congress.
Then they would have the speaker of the House,
Trump, call for a vote to impeach, charge
and remove Biden and Harris, who they refer
to as impostors.
And then step seven is duly impeached.
Charge and remove Biden and Harris, which,
you know, seems very similar to item number
six.
So what's funny is that really the only two
things here that are a plan would be item
number two, which is to win the next election.
And in order to do that, one way to do it
would be, hey, come up with some substantive
policy ideas like win by offering policy that
people like.
No, they're not doing that.
Instead, they're going with option two, which
is try to suppress the vote to win and only
talk about things like communism and critical
race theory or whatever else they are trying
to do that it didn't work in twenty twenty.
They didn't suppress enough of the vote in
twenty twenty, but they came kind of close.
And so we have to really I don't know why
I am really worried about twenty two and twenty
four more than I've been this far in advance
of any recent election.
I think we have to be ready that they almost
suppressed enough of the vote.
They may do it in twenty two and they may
do it in twenty four.